le 37ème salon des arts ménagers a
ouvert aujourd'hui ses portes au public
au cnit à paris
il n'y avait pas encore une très grande
foule quand nous sommes allés pour
filmer quelques unes des nouveautés de
ce salon par exemple cette cabine douche
lavabo en forme d'escargot entièrement
faite d'altuglas fumée représente une
des plus amusantes idées dans le domaine
des sanitaires brancher sur votre
aspirateur ce distributeur de mousse
nettoie moquettes et tapis unis cette
machine à laver française à prix très
abordable et efficace toute nouvelle
cette vaisselle de verre empilables
verres à boire et assiettes tout nouveau
ce petit moulin qui est absolument sans
danger et amusant de forme le contacter
dans la fixation du couvercle
vient de sortir ce petit gris
électriques ainsi que se grille pain de
mie et baguettes hachoir au qui permet
de garder tout son arôme et son jus aux
produits hachés cette année on note des
transformations des améliorations dans
des matériels existants déjà et c'est là
bien souvent que réside la nouveauté de
radiateur le premier déjà connu mais
dont la petitesse de la taille d'une
nouvelle le second électrique petit et
murale cuisinière électrique avec un
programmateur peu compliqué qui
simplifiera beaucoup les problèmes des
maîtresses de maison il ya encore bien
d'autres choses comme ce rasoir mais
vous avez jusqu'au 17 mars pour les voir